so excuse me is your manager here
manager how can I ask a question are you
manager yes but it's from Israel if you
scan the barcode it will show actually
it's from Israel it's writing on the
rece
that these are some of the drinks in my
fridge guys just some of them Subhan
Allah that we drink along water and many
other things many fruits to pick from
many foods to eat from Subhan Allah what
about the people who are starving in
Gaza all around the world who do not
have food to eat how can we make these
drinks these foods go down throat
knowing that they're starving I am
working with one charity for their food
project guys and they are a 100%
donation policy charity I know the
brothers who run the charity and I have
full trust in them that the prophet P
said the Muslim is not the one when his
neighbor is hungry his stomach is
fullam brothers and sisters and dear
friends I saw a video of a brother who
was going into Audi and scanning these
dates who which WR South Africa on them
and when he scans them it shows that
it's actually from Israel so I thought
to myself really really I thought let me
go and find out for myself so I went to
my local Audi here's a video of what
happened I went to the manager AUD as
you guys can see I'm going to go inside
inah uh and ask them and see what
happens obviously I want to be uh
reasonable it's not the manager for on
for the companies we're going to go and
find out in that do they even know why
is it labeled at South Africa but it's
actually from Israel let's see what
happens
in so excuse me is your managing here
it's from Israel it's writing on the
receipt that yeah yeah if you scan it
like for example let me show you I are
you're the manager yeah but yeah I'm
going to go on the office to ask about
it but we are not to wor about it so
which application are you
using you check Audi Audi would
know I'm sure you guys well if if Ali
will know we're going to have a notice I
didn't receive any kind of thank you I
really appreciate thank you thank you
I'm going to go in the office and that
means they going to remove everything
okay thank you I really appreciate thank
you thank you very much
well that's well that's good results
alhamdulillah she was very very friendly
not only that she said we are not even
aware and she goes going to make a
notice and move everything so as you can
see here guys boycot I'm going to be
going to other places as well but um
hopefully I'm going to put a complaining
and we can even all about complaining
inah um and yeah that's that's that's
what it is I came to Al in my local I
don't really shop in Ali know that
there's anything wrong with Audi but at
least they are receptive they are
understanding and they're going to put a
complain in they can remove all of these
and do the same in your local branch
pleas go to the manager and speak to
them please BL I I don't know what to
say I was I was there speechless very
look look she just dealt with the matter
straight away alah and we can also put a
complaint inshallah through to all the
Audi's you guys need to do this to all
the Audis all of them I can't do I'm not
Superman guys I cannot do on my own I'm
doing this videos to encourage you guys
go and do the same thing to every single
manager in Audi across the country so
guys as you saw for yourself Subhan
Allah she was very receptive she said
really oh my God gosh we didn't know if
we knew it don't worry we're going to
take them all
off look at that the moment she found
out she's a she can say you know what
it's going to have to do with me she
could any of that okay no no she can say
you know what yeah sorry no you know
like Ferris you know or Coca-Cola
laughing about it yeah not boycotting it
could have been like that no no no no
this non-muslim woman has more care yeah
than the Coca-Cola drinken FIS can ever
had in his life want anything Cola Cola
zero please oh I'm supposed to be
boycotting H am I supposed to be
boycotting in this video this is what
happened subh Allah and guys I urge you
guys to do the same thing this woman was
absolutely lovely she you heard what she
said you know I thought it would have
been confrontational I showed her she
said oh my gosh yeah it say Israel South
Africa deceiving people automatically
she said yep I'm going to put uh thing
get look into the matter and we're going
to take them off straight away bro
literally straight away no convincing
nothing straight away and then we have
Muslims who care more about their taste
BS Olden co-cola zero because they have
zero character they have zero heart and
they have zero Mercy that's all I have
to say brother sisters do the same
around brother sisters do not miss this
opportunity to hit them where it hurts
says
inshah the whole world is going to see
in and one day Palestine is going to be
free
inshah